What if I add a line to the bottom of this program? What do you think will
happen if I try to compile this code and run it? Will the code compile? Will
there be an error? What age of kitten would trigger this return statement?
Let's try it, the code won't compile. It says unreachable statement. Every
possible branch of this if else statement has a return statement already. Once
it returns the answer it won't do anymore. It'll exit the method. Even if there
might be more code further down. Java can recognize certain situations where
there might be unreachable code and it warns you because unreachable code is a
mistake. When I write this line, I'm coding for a case that can never happen.
All the cases are handled and finished in the if else statement. The else picks
up all of the left overs. So, I shouldn't have an extra line at the end of my
program that pretends it might return the cutest kitten of all..